as the house knows the uk's humanitarian
support for ukraine has been developed
following close consultation with their
government and governments in the region
on the 4th of march i launched the
ukraine family scheme it applies to
immediate and extended ukrainian family
members and everyone eligible is granted
three years leave to enter or remain
today i want to set out further changes
i make into the process
to make it quicker and simpler
i have two overreaching obligations
first to keep the british people safe
second to do all we can to help
ukrainians
no home secretary can take these
decisions lightly and i'm in daily
contact with the intelligence and
security agencies who are providing me
with regular threat assessments what
happened in salisbury showed what putin
is willing to do on our soil it also
demonstrated that a small number of
people with evil intentions
can wreak havoc on our streets
this morning i received assurances which
enabled me to announce changes to the
ukrainian family scheme
based on the new advice i have received
i am now in the position to announce
that vital security checks will continue
on all cases
from tuesday i can announce that
ukrainians with passports will no longer
need to go to a visa application center
to give their biometrics before they
come to the uk
instead once their application has been
considered and appropriate checks
completed they will receive direct
notification that they are eligible for
the scheme and can come to the uk
in short ukrainians with passports will
be able to get permission to come here
fully online from wherever they are and
will be able to give their biometrics
once in britain
this will mean mr speaker that visa
application centers across europe can
focus their efforts on helping
ukrainians without passports
we have increased the capacity those
centers to over 13 000 appointments per
week
and this streamline approach will be
operational as of tuesday the 15th of
march in order to make the relevant
technology and i t changes i will mr
speaker of course update the house if
the security picture changes and if it
becomes necessary to make further
changes to protect our domestic homeland
security
threat assessments are always changing
and we will always keep our approach
under review
in the meantime mr speaker i once again
salute the heroism of the ukrainian
people